Have you ever seen a hand
knitting pattern that you love?
and
thought, "I can knit that on the machine"?
Chances are you can. Let's take a look
at evaluating a hand knitting pattern
and walk through some of the steps
for converting it to machine knitting.
We'll ask three questions.
Can it be done?
Examine the basic shape of the sweater
and the pieces and shaping
that needs to be done.
Is this appropriate for the machine?
If there are large, drapey pieces,
or a very wide pieces,
they could be done either with "U"
knitting with a ribber or
put in some seams.
Second question, is it practical?
Examine the yarn and the stitch patterns.
If the stitch patterns are mostly Garter
stitch, it probably won't work unless you want
to spend a whole lot
of time reforming stitches.
Maybe the yarn has sequins in it,
or has an unusual construction
that might not work on the machine.
something to take into consideration.
Plain stockinette garments
make a whole lot of sense.
A other techniques like entrelac
well, it can be done, but do you
want a spend that much time?
A heavy cables with popcorn stitch
and a lot of Purl stitch accents,  again,
very time-consuming.
Is it practical?
If it's a lace sweater,
how are your programming skills?
Are you willing to hand manipulate
lace over a whole sweater?
Which leads us to the third question.
Are you willing to do what it takes
to knit this garment on the machine?
When I hand knit, it's for the process
of knitting a feeling the yarn,
the joy of watching complicated
stitch patterns develop.
And it's relaxing.
Plus, it's portable.
Examine the hand knitting pattern.
Are you willing to sit a the machine doing
a lot of hand manipulation and hand
shaping, maybe transferring a whole
bunch of stitches or reforming stitches?
If the pattern you're looking
at a met all of these criteria.
Where do you start?
The critical part of this
process is matching the gauge.
Unless you want to do a lot of math
and re-chart the pattern
or enter it into some knitting software.
You must match the pattern gauge.
Exactly.
Not close, but exactly.
Now double check that
there are enough needles on your needle bed for the size.
you want to knit. Find the largest
cast on edge, usually the sweater back.
Multiply it by the stitch gauge.
Occasionally the bind off edge or a band
or a collar may have too many stitches.
Determine all that before you start
knitting, you may be able to plan a seam
in a band in an inconspicuous place,
or a you might consider hand knitting
a section that's too large
for the knitting machine.
You'll have to do a little bit of math.
Because a machine knitters can't
accurately measure the length of their
knitting as they knit,
they need to convert the length
indicated in the pattern to rows.
If there's a schematic,
it makes your job easier.
Just highlight the dimensions
for your size.
And do the math.
This sample sweater has 3 inches
of ribbing. I've multiplied
3 times the row gauge.
A.
I'll know that I need
to knit 10 rows of ribbing.
The body of the sweater is
15.5 inches long or 50 rows.
The Raglan shaping is worked
over 9 inches or 30 rows.
Repeat this for all the piece of your
pattern before you start knitting.
If there's no schematic with the pattern,
read through the knitting
instructions. Again,
look for that largest Cast on or bind off
to determine if it will
fit on your needle bed.
Then look for any length measurements.
The text would read "knit
until the piece measures so many inches".
Or "knit in pattern for so many inches".
Multiply the dimensions given by the row
gauge and substitute your row gauge when
you're knitting. If there's no schematic,
a always find it easier
to sketch out my own.
A insert the numbers,
noting both the row counts and the stitch
counts at the various shaping points.
This really helps when knitting.
Here's a hand knit schematic for a sweater
that's knit in all in one piece.
By adding side seams, we'll have enough
needles to knit this on the machine.
Keep in mind that since we're adding
side seam, we'll need
to add seaming stitches.
Here are the cast on numbers.
We'll knit the length
a instructed by the pattern,
up to the armhole
bind offs. The hand knit pattern reads "knit
45; bind off 10; knit 90;
bind off 10; knit 45.
Then the fronts and backs
are worked separately.
We'll be knitting the body and the armhole
and neckline shaping in pieces,
and we need to remember to add
those seaming stitches.
So here are our machine
knitting instructions.
The remaining armhole a neckline shaping
would be exactly according to pattern.
Now you can knit this sweater
in a fraction of the time.
I encourage you to take a few minutes
to surf the web or look a some sweaters in
catalogs or stores which sweaters
could be made on the machine?
Which ones would be a better knit by hand?
Train your eye and
open yourself to a whole new world
of knitting patterns for your machine.
Thank you for watching
the Knit it Now learning library has
hundreds of tutorials that will
help you be a better knitter.
Please subscribe and join
the knit It Now community.
Happy knitting.